foreign
how do you protect or create the time
for
creativity and making right so if we
think about it as making versus managing
so the making is the creative stuff the
managing is all the meetings all of the
CEO stuff
I would have to imagine there have been
times where you've looked at your
calendar after a hard week and you're
like for [ __ ] sake I've spent 90 plus
maybe 100 of my time this week managing
stuff
how have you
been able to block out or protect the
time to create have you thought about
that as as someone who has all these
different business ventures now
it's the Eternal question we all
struggle with how do we balance our life
we all ask that both on a personal in
the work we're always going how how does
this work
I through
failures Tim found that I was a five
ball juggler
right
and here's what that means
that I don't care who you are I don't
care if you're the best juggler in Vegas
and you're with Cirque du Soleil and you
can juggle 25 balls even that person if
you go one ball more than they're
capable of guess what happens
all the balls fall every ball you're
juggling hits the floor and it's a mess
and so I unfortunately
let the balls drop at times that I was
acutely aware that I was doing a
disservice to certain areas and I
learned that I was a five ball jungler
and here's what that means for me it
means that is I'm always constantly
juggling Fireballs but if another
opportunity comes along and I get
excited about it and it makes sense both
from an artistic and from a business CEO
level I must put one of the five balls I
am currently juggling down
or put it in the hands of others and
give them full trust to do what they
need to do before I pick up that new
opportunity so that I'm constantly at
five and don't extend myself
and so it was a lesson hard learned over
the years and what that also meant was
Todd
you can't do all the artwork yourself so
you're going to have to become a good
scout and you're gonna have to find
talent and at some point on a good day I
feel that I am Phil Jackson when he was
coaching the Chicago Bulls I think maybe
not his conversation went something like
this
Michael Jordan Scottie Pippen and I
don't even know what the name is of the
rest of you dudes
could you guys just go over there or not
your job is could you put that ball in
that bucket oh
by the way
if you have any questions to that
in-depth analysis I just gave you I'll
be over here in my three-piece suit with
my clipboard and you just come over and
ask me a question
and Phil Jackson was smart enough to
find the proper talent and put it in the
proper place so that the end of that run
not only did Michael Jordan have six
championship rings so did Phil and you
know many buckets Phil made during that
time zero he was just smart enough to
know to put Michael and the crew out
there in the right iterations and so
there are times where you have to just
go Todd you can't build this all
yourself there are some things that make
sense for me being the lead and or even
isolating myself artistically there are
plenty of other things we do making toys
making comic book making movies making
video games all of it that's a
collective team and I actually sort of
enjoy being with the collective team
because if I can find my Michael Jordan
to my Scottie Pippins
and I'm in a meeting and they show me
their skill
artistically or with ideas or how to
promote or how to sell or Market
whatever in any field in any sort of
skill set
and I feel like I'm the dumbest guy in
the room those are great days for me Tim
because I sit there and go oh my gosh I
wouldn't have even thought of that I
can't even do it to that skill set thank
God they work for me right and I just
sit there and go hmm and if I really
want to make it look like that I'm sort
of more important that I am I I'll say
something like interesting I'll take it
under revisement and get back to
everybody tomorrow right we're inside
I'm going holy [ __ ] this is awesome I
just hope they don't quit and start
their own company and compete against me
because they're super awesome and so
that's it you have to find talent and
Coach them along the way I'm just a
coach I just I feel like I'm a coach now